and i i've seen these since then when um
comedy started to start back up and then
we had the outdoor show what parking lot
that i run into right it's like didn't
you do a stunt out here years ago they
uh set up um
in an alley in
hollywood boulevard
not the magic castle that was a good gig
yeah i heard about that one wasn't that
one to drive in
well when they first had it they the
first time i did it
i hadn't done stand-up in like
oh man well march was when the [ __ ] hit
right lock down and then we did the i
think i did that in like june or july
so
i i always wanted how people stopped
doing stand-ups like how do you stop
it's so fun how like do you know when
it's your last one right
so
when this pandemic hit remember in the
beginning everyone was like oh this is
gonna be like you know about 14 21 days
everybody stays inside yeah because
that's everybody getting the curve
because everybody's going to play ball
and just listen to the people no
everybody did whatever the [ __ ] they
want to do which is also what makes this
country great
so
uh
then all of a sudden i took a month off
i'm thinking i've been doing this [ __ ]
almost 30 years this is good to take
some time off and somewhere in may
i just stopped even thinking about stand
up just stop thinking about it because i
usually like i see something i'd be like
i'm gonna talk about that that's
basically how i come up with bits i see
something i don't write it down i just
kind of go up and just
riff on the [ __ ] and hopefully it
turns into something and somewhere
around may like i stopped doing that and
i was watching like cooking videos and
[ __ ] like learning souffles or whatever
on the internet and i had this big
[ __ ] panic attack
like going like oh my god like i kind of
like through this virus have sort of
quit doing comedy so
anyway when the first one i did coming
back was that one at the magic castle
and it was outdoors which is always you
know weird you always if you're doing a
show outside you just automatically feel
like you're bombing because like all the
light all the laughs just go up into the
clouds and it doesn't come at you or if
there's like a roof you can feel like
okay they still like me let's see if
they like me after this one right sure
so that was all gone and they were like
in cars
no they handed they had those you know
those stupid things you go like this and
it's two hands clapping
so it's like these plastic things so you
tell a joke
out into this dark parking lot
and there would just be like this brutal
pause that felt like a like a kick to
the chest and then you just hear a
couple
but couldn't they just clap at that
point if they're holding a clapper like
what's the difference were they holding
them outside the window
just told to do something they do i
guess you know nobody doesn't people
don't start to think
and then you have the other people who
think too much and then they start
thinking the world's flat but there's
there's there is a sweet spot yeah
you're on a show could be like or i
could just do this right and then they
were like they would flick their lights
they beeped but but what what i got out
of it
um it was funny it was a one show
adjustment by the second show
like those little tick tick tick tick
tick tick tick things i i i got in the
mindset like oh this is what killing
sounds like all right
or having a good set sounds like but
what i i got out of it was like
like the i was saying when i was on
there i go when this [ __ ] pandemic is
over
and somebody says to you hey man i am
the biggest fan of stand-up comedy you
have to say oh yeah did you sit in your
ford focus in a [ __ ] parking lot with
plastic hands
because you missed hearing jokes i was
like you guys
yeah you're like the people that went
through like the depression or the dust
bowl of like comedy you can say i was
there man i [ __ ] showed up where were
you
america if you thought jackass forever
was crazy oh boy do i have a show for
you it's a multimedia comedy show called
the bucket list tour and the stuff i
filmed for this show is way too hot for
jackass like the general anesthesia bike
ride the vasectomy olympics and sky
jacking the footage is so intense we
have full grown men passing out at
almost every city this bus goes to
so if you think you can handle it get
your tickets right now at stevo.com
[Applause]
you